very happy to be joined now by mike
florio pro football talk pro football
talk live and pro
football talk pm on the peacock network
along with the rich eisen show
mike you on dan what's up man how are
you man i have been reading your stuff
what did you start 20 years ago how long
has pro football talk been around
i stumbled into the business in june of
2000
launched pft november 1
2001. so the 20-year non-celebration is
coming up later this year
the 20-year non-celebration golf clap
for you my friend congratulations it is
a uh
a must read had peter king on yesterday
and pro football talk in
peter king's column uh two mustards all
the time
uh well let's let's dig in i was
watching a little bit of you earlier
today
uh with chris sims also a big fan of
chris and and you
talked a little bit about the deshaun
watson situation which continues to get
worse and worse for desean
and i think there's nobody better on in
the country to talk about this situation
than mike florio
since you practiced law for 17 years
um if you're his lawyer right now what
are you telling deshaun watson to do
i i'm telling deshaun watson why didn't
you listen to me
a month ago when i told you that we
should settle these claims now
i i say that only half facetiously you
know any advice i would give to sean
watson would be premised upon my belief
that he's innocent
of what he's accused of doing i would
not want to represent him if i thought
he was guilty of what he did and i
understand that everyone has a right
to an attorney and eventually there will
be if you're
prosecuted a criminal defense lawyer who
was there with the mission
of forcing the government to prove all
elements
of all charges beyond a reasonable doubt
we all have a constitutional right
to to just sit there and say nothing and
force the government to prove
that we did something above that very
high bar in a civil setting
you don't have those same protections in
a civil setting
it's a much lower standard and i would
not be an effective advocate
if i didn't believe in him completely
and entirely
and frankly if i were called in right
now
to help desean watson the first thing
i'd want to do is line up a polygraph
and i'd want to make sure that he's
telling the truth before i
give him any advice and before i attach
myself
to something that ultimately would
affect my reputation my
integrity if i'm going to stand up and
say he didn't do it
that's how far this has gone with 14
lawsuits and 24 total
women who are making these allegations i
would need to be 100 percent convinced
that he's innocent before moving forward
and with each additional
lawsuit that emerges i think it's harder
and harder to get to the point
where you would believe that nothing
happened in every single one of those
instances
14 women as you mentioned 24 uh could
eventually come forward according to the
the lawyer uh tony busby who is filing
all of these lawsuits um for
the nfl there is an investigation that
is that is already
underway um what are the options for the
league at this point
if this plays out for a month two months
three months
the nfl has very broad power dan to
basically do whatever it believes is the
right thing in any given situation and
the personal conduct policy
is something that was created by pr
concerns
99.9 percent of the employers in america
take the position that
you keep working until you can't work
because you're in jail
and if you plead guilty and you
serve probation or if you're sued and
you lose that doesn't affect your
employment the nfl
created a personal conduct policy that
regulates the things that players do
on their personal time when they're not
at work because the nfl
wants to be able to say we have
responsible
members of society who don't go around
engaging in misconduct so
the nfl has to decide at what point the
pr concerns
require something more than just an
investigation
does the nfl reach its own conclusion
which the nfl now does
post ray rice the nfl no longer defers
to what
the justice system ultimately decides
will the nfl decide to put deshaun
watson on paid leave while these 14
cases go forward and whatever
prosecution potentially
may happen that's something that tony
busby is trying to instigate in houston
although i don't think
prosecution is viable here because of
the very high standard
of proof beyond a reasonable doubt but
these are various options available the
nfl
and i think it's driven by which way the
wind's blowing and how hard the wind is
blowing
and how much of a distraction the nfl
thinks this is but one potential outcome
here
is the texans can't trade deshaun watson
and he gets placed on paid leave
and he gets paid his full salary this
year to not play for the houston texans
while everyone waits and sees how these
cases play out
and just to be clear my perception on
everything i've heard and read
is that the texans obviously as the rest
of us totally blindsided by this right
there was
there they did not see this coming they
didn't see it coming now there's a fair
question to be asked on whether or not
they got a heads up from tony busby i
was not convinced by his explanation at
his press conference last week
when he acted like he didn't know the
first name of the guy who owns the team
you can't be a houston lawyer
very prominent a guy who ran for mayor
and not know that cal mcnair
is the owner of the local nfl team when
he says cal or hal or whatever his name
is
that to me is just one of those one of
those things that doesn't get through
the crap filter
and makes me say something's going on
here and that's something i've been
trying to explain to people there
doesn't have to be a conspiracy theory
at play here
it's as simple as tony busby as part of
his due diligence
when he's evaluating this lawsuit
calling up someone he knows with the
texans
and just saying do you know anything
about this have you heard about this
kind of behavior
this is a heads up for you that there's
an issue
that's quite possibly going to end up
with a lawsuit being filed and they can
say this is all off the record this
conversation didn't happen
we know stuff like that happens all the
time but i'm not buying the idea that
the texans were caught as flat-footed as
we are i would guess
they knew something was percolating
before last tuesday night
when the first lawsuit was filed dan
helly sitting in for rich eyes and
talking to mike florio from pro football
talk
uh as a lawyer mike you see
the way tony busby has approached this
and
it it is desean watson being tried in
the court of public opinion because of
how public
busby has been about everything posting
a lot of different things on instagram
including the letter he got from the nfl
saying that they were beginning to
investigate um right wrong and different
how do you feel about how busby's
approach this i don't like it it doesn't
mesh with my own personal style
but it also has been very effective in
large part because there's been no
response in the court of public opinion
it's basically a no-show by desean
watson
and whoever is advising him legally and
or
on a pr front because it's been busby
unrebutted getting his message out there
saying things that i don't think are
credible when he calls a press
conference
to say that this isn't about publicity
during a press conference right
and when he says it's not about the
money and he tries to convince the
average person who's listening that
we've only asked for the jurisdictional
minimum to get through the courthouse
door
well that gets you through the
courthouse door and using those words
justifies
the court having the case in the first
place
but when you look at the lawsuits
carefully he's not limiting
any potential recovery to five hundred
dollars which is the jurisdictional
minimum
he wants everything he can get there's
nothing wrong with that that's how the
civil justice system works
that's how the powerless gets an even
playing field with the powerful
if the powerful wrong the powerless the
powerless have the ability
to secure a verdict that forces the
powerful to pay
and deters others from engaging in
similar behavior
but from a pr standpoint saying it's not
about the money
saying it's not about publicity those
are things that presumably
advance the cause and again it's worked
because
it's everything buzzby said everything
that's in these lawsuits
unchallenged and unrebutted in the court
of public opinion and with so many
plaintiffs at this point
it becomes very difficult for the
average person who hears about this
to say anything other than he
he's guilty and again in a court of
public opinion
the jurors are all of us and they have
the right to reach whatever conclusions
they want whenever they want
last question about the watson situation
for you mike
in terms of civil versus criminal right
now
everything is civil uh it obviously
would ratchet up
if it became a criminal criminal case
um is that the next step here for
from from a legal standpoint well that's
what busby wants to do as part of his pr
effort and by doing this now see it's
very brilliant because
it short circuits the pr argument that
some are making
and this is not this is not a valid
legal argument
but the well why didn't they go straight
to the police
defense or suggestion well they're going
now
there's no requirement that they
immediately go they're going now
and they're doing it together and busby
is facilitating it he's asking for
the local prosecutor to investigate this
case and empanel a grand jury
but the problem is this the prosecutor
may look at these cases and say
how can i ever prove beyond a reasonable
doubt
when it's desean watson's word against
the word of the person
regarding activities that occur during
the inherently
intimate process of a massage how can i
prove
beyond a reasonable doubt that he
crossed the line
and you know people think the judge in a
given town is the most powerful person
the prosecutor is the most powerful
person the judge only handles
what someone puts in his or her
courtroom the prosecutor
is the one who decides with broad almost
unfettered discretion
who gets prosecuted and who doesn't and
most prosecutors
will only take on cases that they know
they can win
all right let's move on to free agency
uh quickly mike they
uh have spent a lot of money have the
patriots and and the giants and i think
everybody has spent more money than
we anticipated uh peter king laid out
how every team has a third of the money
to spend that they had
a year ago yet we're seeing some massive
contracts here
is there one particular contract or
maybe two that really caught your
attention
well you lump in the giants and the
patriots together and they've got the
obvious connections from their past
super bowls but i think the patriots
with all the contracts they signed they
knew exactly what the market was for
these players
ahead of time shocking tampering happens
and communications happen before
the monday when the negotiating window
opens and i
suspect that the patriots very
surgically made sure that every dollar
was being spent
in a way where there wasn't a much of a
gap between whatever the patriots
offered and whatever someone else was
going to offer
the two contracts the giants have signed
in recent days between kenny gallaudet
and adore jackson
these guys combined to play in eight
games last year
combined between two of them eight total
games
and you look at over 100 million dollars
in contractual value and i know with
gallaudet
there was no one else offering close to
18 million a year i don't know who the
giants were competing against to get him
the the next closest that i'm aware of
is the bengals at 13.
with jackson i don't know who else was
in play and for how much
but i have a feeling that they overshot
with that as well you know sometimes
teams just like let's get it done
we we can't we can't play this game of
who else is out there we may lose the
guy
but that's the difference between the
patriots and the giants to me i suspect
the patriots
got the best possible deal they could
with every guy they signed and i'm just
kind of surprised that so much money
changed hands
with gallaudet and jackson given the
injury issues that kept them
to to such relatively small playing time
last year
i talked to mike tannenbaum uh last week
on my podcast and he said
let's talk two weeks from now he said i
think i could build a playoff team
from the number of free agents quality
free agents that are still going to be
out there and i'm looking at the list
now
and i think we're all a little surprised
by the number of guys we've been signed
there's not that many quality guys left
everybody has an asterisk i think next
their whether it's age or coming off
injury
are there one or two guys out there now
who who you think are gonna be the next
choose to drop for
a decent sized contract well you know
we've seen now that that guys like sammy
watkins are
are being brought in for visits but i
don't expect him getting any
anything more than a one year six seven
million dollar deal given his injury
history
giant contract i just don't think
they're out there this year
you know it's it's going to be for most
of these guys a one or a two year thing
and if i was the player i would want a
one year deal and i would want to get
right back at it next year when the
salary cap begins going up again
you know even though the cap's down 15
million it was supposed to go up 10 it's
gone up at least 10
every year since 2013. it's a 25 million
dollar gap
and and yeah there are plenty of
recognizable names out there they're
going to get squeezed to take less
now they may wait until training camp
they may wait until september they may
wait until october they may wait beyond
that
i've i've heard some speculation maybe
guys will sit out the whole year
although one thing we know about the nfl
the train keeps rolling without you and
you quickly become out of sight out of
mind as far as the nfl is concerned and
i think even a guy who isn't happy with
what he's offered
if he wants to try to get a good deal
next year
it's in his best interest to find a
place to play this year
last question for you mike draft um
we've been hearing
adam schefter say there's going to be
four quarterbacks in the first seven
picks
uh mike tannenbaum told me he thought in
the first eight we were going to see
four quarterbacks go um you work with
chris sims and
and he he has a very different
quarterback ranking than some other guys
i i believe
um it was zach wilson over trevor
lawrence am i correct there yeah he's
got zach wilson at number one he
he he still thinks the jaguars could and
will and should take trevor lawrence but
he's got wilson at one
what what's going to be in your mind i'm
asking you to be a soothsayer here a
little bit
but maybe somebody who moves in to that
first uh
six or seven picks or or somebody who
picks a quarterback that you didn't
expect to pick a quarterback
well look when you when you watch what
the bears in washington have done
over the past week by adding veterans at
one year 10 million dollar contracts and
ryan fitzpatrick and andy dalton that
removes the glaring
watch us take a quarterback sign that
otherwise would be attached to them
when we start getting through the teens
and and the question becomes how many
guys
survive the first five six seven picks
how many quarterbacks are left
how many guys are sliding down the board
and
i think that you know the teams most
likely
to surprise us are the teams where we
think
they have their situation taken care of
and
they've got a one-year band-aid starter
at a relatively reasonable price for a
starter
those are the teams that i would be
watching if there's some guy they love
and of course they need to keep their
mouth
shut or put out misinformation they
don't want anyone to know exactly
what it is they're thinking but i'd
watch those teams where
we know there isn't an answer beyond
this year
and the answer for this year is still a
little bit tenuous
i think those are teams that potentially
could move but you know
hey there's three types of teams in the
nfl teams that have franchise
quarterbacks
teams that are desperately looking for
franchise quarterbacks and teams that
have a guy that they're not quite sure
whether or not he's going to be a
franchise quarterback
and there's a lot of teams in category
number two even teams that have starters
they don't have franchise quarterbacks
and they're always looking for that guy
and one team i think that falls into
that category is the new england
patriots right now picking at
15. they have cam coming back for a year
a lot of people pegging maybe mac jones
to
go there i'm talking to somebody earlier
today said they wouldn't be surprised if
mac jones fell out of the first round
but
i just for all the quarterback thirsty
teams i know mack jones doesn't
knock your socks off but i would be
shocked if he fell out of the first
round wouldn't you
yeah he he's the kind of guy who once he
starts creeping down through the 20s
there'll be somebody who swoops in
to the bottom of the round to get him
and to get that fifth year option
on his contract something we've seen
happen regularly
really since the the 2011 cba that that
made
every round but round one a four-year
contract and gave that 50-year option
whether it's teddy bridgewater lamar
jackson
guys go late around one because it gives
the team more flexibility so i
i'd be stunned if jones falls out of
round one there are people who think he
still goes top ten
so uh but that's part of the fun of it
and you know quarterbacks are what drive
the league
and there's so many great young
quarterbacks
there's even more reason now to fully
and completely
vet the young quarterbacks coming in
we're a long way removed
from jake locker blaine gabbard
christian ponder taking 8
10 and 12 in 2011 and that was a true
roll of the dice they know these
quarterbacks a lot better now
than they ever have before mike florio
you still
you able to do everything from home in
west virginia i have not traveled on
business since
the combine in 2020 how about that wow
i don't know if that's good or bad yeah
ask my wife that question
you'll get the answer quickly uh mike
florio pro football talk pro football
talk live pro football talk
pm uh you start the day and you finish
the day
right here on peacock with mike florio i
highly recommend you check him out
obviously you've been uh going to his
site if you're a football fan like
myself for 20 years now
mike congratulations on the success my
friend and uh hey thanks for being there
i mean
literally i feel like i i i check your
site as much as i
i check my stock portfolio uh on a daily
basis these days i'm very excited about
it
well that's very good and and you can
never lose money by checking my website
you might not make much but you're not
going to lose any i feel a lot better
checking pro football talk thanks mike
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here